[Musique]
tu
un petit peu de nos projets que nous prévoyons en fait,
comme nous marier la semaine où
tout a été fermé, alors nous allons juste
attendre et ensuite nous avons entendu dire
qu'ils allaient avoir des cérémonies ici
alors  profitez-en ouais, ils sont
censés se marier dimanche à
Maui avec leur famille et cela a été annulé
alors lundi nous avons appelé et nous avons été
déçus,
c'est triste mais une partie de l'histoire au moins nous
pouvons dire que nous sommes mariés et faire une petite
fête après
nous avons tendance à inviter des gens que personne ne peut venir, il
fallait juste qu'il s'agisse d'un seul témoin de la
bonne famille ou quelque chose comme ça, donc c'est
le problème que nous avions et
ensuite nous essayions d'aller dans un endroit en location où
ils ne le faisaient pas maintenant, donc nous  Je ne
savais pas que Wimmer allait
commencer jusqu'à ce que nous décidions de le faire.
[Musique]